so you've just given a speech on
something I know that is very important
to you which is the potential
partnership between the private sector
and government when it comes to climate
change what is it that you are asking
the private sector to do but they
wouldn't otherwise do make energy
conscious decisions in their business in
the plant that they produce how they
power their plant where they do it and
also in their choices for national
policy with respect to energy we need to
move rapidly to a low-carbon energy
based economy and that would be not only
significant in terms of our emissions
and all the negative consequences that
come from the climate but it's the
greatest economic opportunity the world
is looking at today there are millions
of jobs to be created in making those
energy conscious decisions and by the
way a lot of savings for companies if
you power your plant more efficiently
you can save millions of dollars
literally so our CEOs and investors just
missing the boat there are lots of
companies increasingly major companies
in the country understand as Walmart is
engaged in working to deal with climate
change Pepsi coca-cola General Electric
I can run a long list of America
brand name companies that are doing it
but lots of other people are also
engaged at lower and smaller levels to
make wiser choices about their energy
use and energy productions and are you
encouraging the government take
regulatory steps to account differently
for the costs of some of the climate
change well we're not a regulatory step
but we would urge I mean accounting is
supposed to be a sort of exercise in
transparency and accountability and
truth real figures real accounting the
real accounting on energy today does not
take into account the costs that we pay
the American taxpayer is paying enormous
sums of money as I mentioned today 70
billion dollars for our Akane sandy the
storms by every scientists account are
more intensive today I can't say that
one storm or another was the precise
effect of the climate moment but i can
tell you
that the intensity of storms generally
is up as a consequence of climate change
more flooding more droughts more melting
of glaciers we depended on migration of
certain species of plants certain
species of animals fish are now
migrating to find colder waters again
there's just a huge transformation
taking place that has potential negative
consequences but the accounting needs to
reflect those realities